foreign
so as it happens we're in the middle of
making another really awesome anime
video most anime adaptations are pretty
bad I've got my own theories for why
they're bad but today let's dive in and
figure that out exactly the best animes
achieve a way of Storytelling and
pulling your emotions around that even
some of the best movies struggle with so
what is that magic why is Anime so
powerful when it's good and why do
movies struggle to reach those same
Peaks or take a look at these compare
some of the originals to the live action
remakes and see where they went wrong or
where they went right so when we keep
shooting this anime video that we're
making it'll be the best it can be the
first thing we need to look at is Cowboy
Bebop
foreign
it is one of the most recent
high-profile Hollywood adaptations of
anime Cowboy Bebop is a classic anime
came out in 1998 and it's kind of known
for launching this music to storytelling
to Vibe connection that you see in a lot
of anime these days plus really invented
like worlds really vibrant characters
amazing animation for like body language
and body movement hits and it cooks and
it's just fun
in the first episode of Cowboy Bebop pay
attention here to how much we learn
about the character how efficient and
economic the story is with the
storytelling in this animation and how
once things are delivered we move on to
something else interesting right away
looking for this character moment right
there the Spiker healing that he
pickpocketed him oh he's Sly he's a fox
he's got this guy they're specifically
not revealing the character until you
have this like stylish intro so you got
some theatrics in it operatic
storytelling that's actually something
I've noticed in a lot of anime that they
do really well which is there's zero
qualms about hiding someone's face until
the time's right it's Peak drama like
the money reveals himself it's also a
challenge to a fight and at the same
time that's when you first see the
character
and so you have a fight scene here right
but this fight scene is telling you a
story immediately Spike's not using his
hands right he's sure of himself he's
cocky and when they want to show you his
emotion they cut to a shot of his face
it's all character based this guy's got
rage and power there's danger there that
table got destroyed so Spike gets hit he
gets hurt but no he's cool he's a
character that guy's not fast enough on
his drug to dodge a punch and Spike's
kicking his butt
[Music]
I feel like for some reason slow motion
has been relocated to just dodging crap
now like ever since the matrix it's like
oh
in this all a slow motion is for the
impacts it's not the Dodges it's once
the flesh meets the flesh now we're in
slow motion it's like whoa boom the face
is going and contorting and blood and
spit it's like an opposite approach to
using that technique
so when the goons show up they serve a
very specific purpose to interrupt the
fight and to give this guy a chance to
get away and look at this more story
right every single moment of story she
wasn't pregnant turns out it's a bunch
of drugs she's smuggling them huge shift
in the character right there goons
they're stopping Spike jet shows up
takes care of the goons done that's it
it's that fast it's brevity it's
economical the Netflix remake of Cowboy
Bebop has the same scene you're gonna
kill your way to Mars instantly the
character reveal totally different also
this is taking a lot longer to get
through the character moment that the
animation version already covered
Spike's cool he's gonna take control the
amount of time it took me to say that
it's the amount of time they should have
shown it Spike's still standing there
staring at this dude
and staring at this dude
and staring at this dude
and staring at this dude not interested
hits him no emphasis on the impacts they
may have well just not have happened
that guy may have just stripped they
could have done that in slow motion by
the way if I was gonna make this scene
more anime I would have probably started
right there
all right goons are showing up and now
the scene's running into some problems
here right so you have like a boss goon
character you have jet here you have
Spike here you have the guy and you have
the girl that's a lot of characters for
a scene and now they're going to try to
do the whole like I'm not pregnant it
turns out it's Drugs in My Tummy kind of
gag now it should just be a moment
between her and her boyfriend becomes
the moment between her and Spike jet the
Goon and everybody else you have
multiple cameras covering it and then
the editors just go and they pick the
best shots for the best moments based on
what you got but that doesn't work for
anime because you don't have shots that
have purpose when you're doing animation
it's not like oh which angle of
Animation should we choose from like no
like people haven't drawn it twice yet
they're gonna draw it one time and you
need to choose what it's going to look
like yeah and in that process you can
make any story feel big because you're
highlighting the emotions perfectly but
in this case they made a big story feel
small so as long as we keep the shots
evolving and like always changing and
always matching the tone of the moment I
think that's going to help a ton the
moment a story beat is hit
move on
Ghost in the Shell have some of the
coolest action sequences in any anime
I've ever seen and I just think we
should watch it because it's awesome
anime destruction that's so good there's
something about it that captures this
like explosiveness it reminds me of like
John Woo
it's a Lobby scene from The Matrix we're
gonna probably talk about the Matrix a
lot Matrix is the best live-action anime
adaptation even though it's not anime
but anyways The Matrix is super inspired
from the sequence it's your classic
highly destructive columns action scene
with big bullets
I love that hold on can we just talk
about the muzzle flashes and like him
shooting this thing muzzle flash impact
circular like Halo flaring around the
impact dust shock waves coming up around
him it's so beautiful like it shows so
much like force and impact watch The
Exit Wounds on the bottom of the tank
damn look at the balcony cracks from the
shock wave of the gun oh my God it's
such a concussive burst of gunfire that
the thing he's standing on is shaking
and falling apart man these movies just
don't do guns Justice
the bullet hits are really underwhelming
I'm seeing like a bunch of dust but I'm
not seeing like holes in the wall when I
think about anime I also think about
stylized physics you have like the water
streamers you have the weird musculature
that's like straining the slow motion
explosions
oh God look at that once again slow
motion for the part that counts
expressive physics it's expressive
physics it's like this thing is so tough
to deal with watch her go all out and
push herself to the very limit to kill
it and then fail that's a heavy hitter
let's watch the live action version I'm
really curious to see how they do this
I'm not looking forward to it
foreign
really hard right now let's look at the
original one can't see my eyes I'm
wearing goggles the struggle's not about
her face it's about her muscles people
in Hollywood hate putting masks on
characters you see this in the Marvel
films so much they're like iron man is
supposed to wear a mask like how are you
gonna say his face
we have to show his face you know and
then anime they're like we don't give a
[ __ ] like hide his face I don't care
like we're not paying like the drawing
you know like we're paying the artist
we're paying the voice actor you could
still be a good actor and wear a mask
all right character reveal expressive
posture not just standing but like chill
and now in the movie
section who's our character they're
standing here
and
it's got the children
and she's not wearing her mask even
though like the whole point of this
opening scene is she's using the mask to
get data and Recon she's just standing
there like looking at the skyscraper
that's like 20 blocks away she's getting
no information it feels like the
director here is serving marketing and
not serving the character and it's not
look here's the character doing
important character things in the world
it's look at the actress we have the
other one character comes first world
comes first everything else comes
afterwards couldn't even done this
foreign
you've seen someone take their
sunglasses off dramatically before right
like
my big takeaway from from this is we
need to have actors who are always
accessible and we need to be able to
shoot somewhere that's always accessible
not constraining us that would help our
priority should be make the best shots
you possibly can
all right all right they're gone so Sam
and Nico are actually downstairs right
now regaining their strength to prepare
for the next round of comparisons we're
gonna make while they do that I'm gonna
take a little bit of time here to tell
you about our sponsor today which is
storyblocks it's a One-Stop shop for all
your stock content needs they got HD
footage they got music sounds mograph
templates you name it they got what you
need to make your editing process and
your content creation process as
seamless and easy as possible without
having to go out and get these high
budget shots or these aerial shots or
like hiring a mograph designer to make
you fancy title templates if you're
trying to get a professional look on any
aspect of video production storyblocks
will really help you with that we use
them all the time here at quarter
recruit it's probably safe to say that
almost every video on this channel uses
the storyblocks asset in there at some
point to complete the visual side of a
lot of the videos we make and it's just
part of our everyday workflow now once
you go there and you look at the site
you're going to be like wow this is a
tool I've been missing out on my whole
content creating life let me get it let
me get on that so if all this stuff
sounds like something you'd like to have
in your creative tool kit then head on
over to storyblocks.com quarter crew
there's a link down in the description
below but they have something for
everyone so head on over that's
storyblocks.com corridorcrew and with
that let's get back to talking about
some anime is Jan here
no okay he is coming
yeah he is coming there is one thing
about anime we have not talked about yet
the internal monologue the internal
monologue so that's why we should watch
a little Death Note even if he has as
many as 50 people on the case I don't
see how they could ever figure out that
I'm Kira
weird was he saying something but his
mouth wasn't moving above all I need my
stalker's name once I figure that out I
can get rid of him for good it doesn't
feel goofy because it's incredibly
serious he's talking about killing
somebody he's talking about killing
himself it's like how do you do that in
live action so in manga you have thought
bubbles I mean heck in a book you can
read what people are thinking about and
like what they're feeling this is why
Sherlock Holmes started off as books
it's like you're solving Mysteries and
there's a lot of thinking and logic like
didn't they do this when he's like
punching them and stuff and like her
fights first distract Target
then block his blind jab count with
cross to left cheek
yeah like there is actually some inner
monologue there and it's so effective
when you really need it Hollywood
filmmaking almost never has narration
happening internal monologues God help
you if you use voice over in your work
my friends it's flaccid sloppy riding
but it's such an interesting way to gain
insight into like what people are
thinking to let you truly appreciate the
character better which is at the end of
the day what this all serves relax light
while it's true the killer hates losing
it's also true that most people would
rather win and lose it's Human Nature
you're going to think that I'm Kira if I
go for the win it's like a great scene
but if you think about it a lot it's
hilarious it's almost two and a half
minutes of characters talking in their
heads to each other this is so good wait
see this is something really awesome
which is it lets you take any story and
make it epic all we need is to know that
somebody cares so much about this thing
you know they'll do anything to get it
and this problem is in the way and if
they don't solve that problem it's just
gonna be awful that can really be as
small as like I need a cup of water I'm
gonna be as big as like this asteroid is
going to destroy the Earth because
really the scale doesn't matter it's how
good you hit the Peaks and valleys of
the story that's all that really matters
all right well they made this for real
foreign
visual storytelling
intentional physics
whoa oh boy love it oh I love it
that's chunky yeah I feel like every
single shot was planned they all serve
an exact purpose in the scene yeah I
feel intention I feel planning I feel
like the characters are being served
like they're not trying to hit marketing
like it's not Willem dafogai in the
background the whole time like it's not
like the first shot is his face
and then he puts a mask on yeah it's
like they're not showing him they're
keeping him in the dark it's cool
they've at least been able to overcome
the challenge of like making it function
you know what I'm saying they're not
like tying themselves down to the
original so much that it prevents them
from making a competent film I think
what it could use if it wanted to be
anime it's just a way to emphasize those
Peaks and valleys even more
oh yeah go
[Music]
I need another bullet here at Nico
[Music]
[Applause]
Nick good work Nick how do you get that
you teleported so we just talked up a
big game right so we have no excuses we
better hit the mark and it's actually
going to be an incredibly special one
because it's going to be our first anime
one that actually looks like anime it's
gonna be pretty pretty crazy the big
thing is from a story perspective when
we look at anime we see Focus we see
intense intention and how it pairs with
the visuals we see passion and
playfulness in the story extreme highs
and lows and getting us there by
whatever means necessary let's achieve
those in our anime piece so we're
already hard at work on this anime video
it's gonna be cranking away for the next
couple weeks here when it comes out if
you watch this video hopefully you see
some of the things we talked about here
applied to that video that we just made
okay so most of these adaptations we've
been looking at are of the like
westernized Hollywood versions of anime
and that's not the totality there's tons
of actual adaptations that are made in
Japan and don't even get me started on
Bollywood films if there's any awesome
adaptations you've seen let us know in
the comments below I mean we're actually
we're real dudes here that like actually
like watching this stuff so hey leave us
some recommendations
this is what real dudes look like
we're just like really we're just real
dude we're just real dudes hey the
camera Cuts Sam time to go back to being
real
dudes